Geno Auriemma joining us the Continental
Tire coaches corner with the UConn head
coach and he joins us now how are you
coach congratulations listen my friends
know I was just on hold listening to you
babbling about which phone coverage I
should have who's dropping their calls
now it's the Continental Tire god only
knows what you're wearing
with what logos on it you are reminding
me were more of a NASCAR driver every
time I talk to you I have an Olympic
jacket on right now from NBC so I'm
flying the red white and blue gene oh
I'm glad to see you're in midseason form
in our in our relationship but congrats
that that was fun to watch but how was
the celebration compared to previous
years any different a little bit a
little bit different I think the
emotions were a little bit different
these kids the seniors especially the
three of them they knew they were on on
a on a quest for something special
they never shied away from it they
didn't pretend that you know it didn't
exist they embraced it and God bless
them they they went after it
they didn't hope that they won didn't
stumble into the history books
they just weren't or absolutely
incredible Dan are you a big pregame
speech guy actually not that much I'm
not because I think at some point you
know they look at you like really so I
kind of try to be honest with them like
if we're playing a team that's really
bad hey guys these guys are really bad
right so let's not be just a little bit
better than a bad team I mean so you
can't go one win one for the Gipper like
you know every two weeks last night you
know we we really did talk a little bit
about okay this is where you wanted to
be this is the point you want it to be
at where you're 40 minutes from making
history so
that's the first time all year that I've
kind of invoked that what's the last
time your women made you cry any woman
that's like everyday you know when I
come home no the girls the women's team
are you telling me that you you would go
home and your wife like you'd look at
her and going like you're dealing with
all these girls at practice and then you
go home like looking for advice from her
on yeah how to deal with them yeah how
about that
like I would come home and we I would
come home and I will go you know dammit
you know you're not gonna Britt and she
would go you know get over it you're not
that important about that and anybody
who has you know anybody who's married
and has daughters you know exactly what
I'm talking about don't ever ask a woman
for advice on how to deal with other
women so when's the last time your
basketball team made you cry that's a
good point it it's happened this group
certainly did you know that 95 team
obviously did 91 Final Four team did sue
Byrd's senior year did when Dianna
graduated did you know you just kind of
get caught up and the fact that you're
part of some specialness and it's
leaving and it's hard it really is hard
I know people like to rank and rate and
III want to phrase it differently than
the best player you've had I think the
most important player you've ever had at
UConn might be a different answer than
the best player you've ever had yeah it
really is you know when you when you
talk about who was there at the
beginning or who got you through a
certain over certain hump that puts you
in another level you know there's
something about each championship that's
one of the things that I I talked about
last night with some of our former
players these 11 championships don't
necessarily you know collectively go wow
you know we have 11 championships each
one
is kind of framed in an era of a certain
iconic player and that's the way I've
kind of chosen to look at it so you know
there was the Rebecca Lobo era there was
the you know the dinosaur assi thing and
suber thing and then my a more saying
and you know the Stewie thing and it
really makes you appreciate the fact
that not these these that that's the
closest Dan comparison that I have with
UCLA when people talk about John Wooden
use the iconic players that I remember
as a kid that played for UCLA it's kind
of how I feel about the kids that I've
coached do you want to be compared to
John Wooden no not in a million years I
hate it money and I'm sitting here in
Indiana right now and I hate it where he
was from yeah you know I don't like it
because you know hey if the population
is gonna say well you know you're not
John Wooden and I'm I'm gonna go of
course I'm not of course and then the
other half that never saw any UCLA
schemes go you could never do what he
did
well actually we did because when they
played it was exactly like the way
women's basketball is today so there's
no winning that argument and I coach a
difference for it although in our era
today we are kind of what UCLA was back
then players stayed all through their
college careers you're able to build a
team you know and look where the game of
men's basketball went so hopefully we
can do for you know women's college
basketball what Coach wood and his UCLA
it seems to for Ben's basketball
he's Geno Auriemma the UConn women's
head coach another national championship
but you understand I don't know if you
feel the same pressure or is a different
pressure but coach wouldn't that the
pressure got to it because he had to win
a national title every single year can
you write can you relate to that yes and
I don't like it I don't like it and and
I I say to myself a lot of times do I
really want to be in this situation year
after year after year after year you
know it it unless you been
in that and you say well come on you
know how hard can it be
you have you know here's the mentality
you have the best players you know you
you get all the best players in the
country which is like a joke we get two
or three we don't get to all of them but
this perception that you know if it's
like probably how is it coaching
managing the Yankees it must be pretty
cool huh well only if you win the World
Series otherwise it sucked so yeah could
you see yourself like you're 62 right
correct okay
John Wooden was 64 when you retired I
know in some cases I want to be like
wouldn't I love you how long do you you
can announce your retirement now if you
want to Gina
only if I got a chance to take over your
show a couple days a week I made a third
of your salary then I'd be alright
is that what it's going to take because
I know Notre Dame will pitch in
Tennessee
Baylor Stanford there's a there's a few
schools around the country that would
pitch in to pay for your salary for you
to join me
absolutely but do you really do see
yourself coaching at linear 70 ah geez
oh man I you know in today's day and age
Dan I'm not sure I'm not sure I mean I
know I can keep doing this as long as I
keep getting the kind of players that
I'm coaching today I don't even mean
like that kind of talent like
transcendent talent like Stewie Brian
and Morgan tuck I'm talking about the
kind of kids and I'm coaching I could do
it I could do it but it's getting harder
I got to tell you was Dan Shaughnessy at
the game last night you know he was but
somebody pointed him out to me I face is
all his name wrong so I wasn't sure
whether he was there or not I'm not sure
could you take Dan Shaughnessy if you
had to what do you mean you know what I
mean take him yeah I know he went to
Holy Cross I went to like some Schmo
yeah with me you're from Philadelphia no
yeah yeah yeah I know but he writes for
the globe you know yeah he's got a cover
Boston College on a yearly basis so
maybe he's not that happy
guy III I'll leave you with this and
it's just my opinion that I think
college basketball needs to come up to
you I didn't I never thought you guys
were bad for basketball I never
understood that logic or that angle or
whatever people were saying I I grew up
loving UCLA
I never thought UCLA was bad for
basketball I just thought everybody had
to get better and that's the way I view
it with women's college basketball
Tennessee used to be great you got to
their level and then you rose above them
somebody's gonna get to your level
eventually and then rise above you and
you know that's that's just the way
sports work so of course it does of
course it does day and I'm glad you
brought that up when I was a kid I
idolized UCLA I knew every kid on the
scene you know I knew all their stats I
couldn't wait to watch them in the NCAA
tournament I was in high school I bet on
a free game with my friends I'm not
allowed to say their poverty but hey and
and and you know what they made college
basketball nationally famous the floor
UCLA
college basketball on the men's I was
regionally famous so UCLA did that and
then after a while everybody said hey
you know what maybe we should aspire to
do that and I hope that that's the case
with women's basketball Congrats and
thanks for joining us great talk to you
again it's always great to talk to you
my friend Thank You Gina Geno Auriemma
head coach women's basketball team yeah
I met him telling me that story like he
had to deal with women's issues at
practice and dealing with their
personalities and you know he said that
time of the month and I go home and I
say to my wife my wife starts yelling at
me like who are you to be talking about
that
like like he said I'd get yelled at when
I went home I'm just trying to
understand why my girls are in different
moods what a character
the Coaches Corner which Geno Auriemma
brought to you by Continental Tire the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience